[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone my name is Noah
Jessup I'm the founder of proof group
but before we dive in today I want to
feel some of the energy in this
room all right so I'm going to say
Network and you
say
network network
network okay now with that same energy I
want you to give a thunderous Round of
Applause and a huge warm welcome to my
my friend the one and only
[Applause]
[Music]
bology all right folks um so we've got a
little QR code uh which will be on
screen in a second um for you to scan
and uh this is your proof of attendance
okay if you want you can take a photo of
it and then scan it later if you want to
do that or just scan it now um and uh
I'm G to give some opening remarks um
you know there's a saying tell them what
you're going to tell them then tell them
then tell them what you told them okay
so um we've got a bunch of speaker save
we're going to go licky split through
the whole thing it's going to be almost
like Tik Tock style but in person okay
very fast and and hopefully really good
so um that by the way that that QR code
is also there on the monitors if you
missed it so it's in the in the back in
the in the white box if you need it okay
so today's conference what's what what's
it about um so there's Theory there's
practice and then there's a conference
itself let's talk
theory um so uh in terms of theory
oops are new countries even possible
right uh we started new companies like
Google we started new communities like
Facebook we started new currencies like
Bitcoin and ethereum could we start new
countries that's a concept of the
network shape and I wrote a book on this
IDE herea you might have heard of it um
it's available for free at the network
state.com uh V1 put going to put out V2
the hard cover make a movie and so on
maybe you guys will be in it um and um
so so this is you know pretty cool
Theory and here's a visual of that
theory here's a visual of the concept if
Bitcoin is a decentralized currency the
network state is a decentralized country
right where it's got the population of a
country but it's all distributed around
the world rather than concentrated in
one place just like the nodes of Bitcoin
are all around the world rather than in
one place and how do you build something
like this well you can actually there's
a path to get to the Cloud country to go
from you know not just zero to one but
one to one million here's an example if
there was a Satoshi in Japan okay living
in a building by themselves um if they
can build a community of let's say 17
people and then 172 they start getting
uh rooms together start you know renting
together eventually they have enough
money to start crowdfunding buildings or
floors eventually they have enough money
in scale at 17,000 to get maybe little
culde saacs or suburbs or what have you
and going up another order of magnitude
they're actually at the scale of a very
small un listed country and one more at
1,729 314 people it's a cloud country
somewhere between laia and Bahrain okay
in terms of its size and scale in
population and income and real estate
footprint okay so this is the concept
nothing here violates any laws of
physics um it's just using internet
Technologies we already have like
crowdfunding and social networking and
and you know VR and zoom and all this
type of stuff but this is the theory and
that's cool but how does it work in
practice okay and so that's what really
today's conference is about how do we
turn that theory into practice and if we
talk about
practice I'm going to introduce A New
Concept today uh which is the parallel
establishment okay so imagine a thousand
different startups each of them
replacing a different Legacy institution
so for example at the top there's San
Francisco and we're replacing San
Francisco
both uh with things outside it like
culdesac in Arizona and prospera in
South America and cabin which is in
Texas but also around the world and the
neighborhood SF is actually fixing San
Francisco from within SF right so you
can have the Satoshi strategy of going
outside or the Sean Adela strategy of
reforming within either Satoshi or seia
is fine so long as you're not Steve who
says it ain't even broke Steve bomber
okay so um so San Francisco replaced San
Francisco with these startup you know
societies then in the middle is Harvard
right we take out Harvard uh and we have
parallel education that's repli that
synthesis which is K through 12 but it's
also AI tutoring the teal Fellowship
emergent Ventures are going to hear from
some of the founders of these today and
then the last row there is another
example we replace media with parallel
media it's Twitter and X it's substack
you're going to hear from the author the
great lady wink today and many other
people doing parallel media okay and so
this concept of the parallel
establishment if you take up all of
these new institutional Replacements on
the right hand side together that's a
parallel establishment they're they
exist alongside the Legacy in parallel
they're gaining strength they're pulling
away users until they become the new
thing okay so this is how we turn that
seemingly impossible thing of building a
new country break into a bunch of
individual startups and then aggregate
them together there's two parts of the
parallel establishment there's a
parallel societies okay and these are
the physical societies right these are
the the first part of today's conference
is about these to show that this is
actually physical and real okay you're
going to see about a dozen of these
physical startups societies there's
culdesac in Arizona there's prospera as
I mentioned in South America there's
cabin in Texas but these are actually
decentralized they plan to do nodes
elsewhere that's just their first nodes
okay they're all kind of network cities
or network societies that are setting up
little nodes around the world um and uh
so this is how we build internet first
physical infrastructure we've got
internet first communities that are
recruited from the internet these are
the kinds of places CAC for example is
like a remote optimized City like if you
built a normal City with roads for the
daily commute What a remote optimized
City look like if it was built for
remote workers you totally rethink all
the architecture it's walkable you don't
have cars everywhere the cars are on the
outside they're self-driving it rethinks
every piece of the infrastructure and
these startup societies are doing things
like that okay so these are the parallel
societies and the other piece of the
puzzle are the parallel institutions
okay so you can almost think of it as
like a a vertical strategy of building a
new city in place and a horizontal
strategy of replacing media and
education and finance okay and those two
are are complimentary the vertical and
the horizontal so the second part of
today's uh uh conference is about the
parallel institutions here you know
these are the new New York Times and
Harvard's the new Supreme Courts and
Wall Streets um it's its internet first
versions of medicine and law and media
and education and finance and even
science itself a diei this example on
the right is um for parallel education
so repet has 20 million repli developers
is transforming Computer Science
Education worldwide synthesis AI
tutoring so you be able to scale
tutoring and the teal Fellowship you
know Teal's unicorn success is awkward
for colleges we have the teal Fellowship
one the co-founders right here is going
to talk to you later
today so that's a theory and practice
and they come together in this
conference and I'm just going to briefly
um say you know who the speakers are and
and then you're going to hear from the
speakers themselves so we're going to
begin with uh five physical parallel
societies okay uh cabin the neighborhood
SF Nomad prais and culdesac in many ways
there different different ways of
materializing cloud communities onto the
land okay and again some of them are
outside of SF some of you know
neighborhood SF is within SF uh and uh
you know they're complimentary
strategies then we'll hear for four more
physical societies from prospera from
fractal from uh Vibe camp and from
Spectra and um these are by you know
Founders who've already built cities
who've already had large exits very very
credible people who are who have either
built or in the process of building
we're also going to hear from three
uh Builders of houses towns and cities
so Bill cover is building Like Houses uh
Sherin pvar first investor in Uber has
built a town and then um sefan zingerle
of Kasa roscom has actually built entire
cities in Africa and he's going to show
you those okay so and those the reason
is the reason those complimentary those
are complimentary is like just like a uh
in computer science you might have
Innovation at the level of the the
database but then a higher level at the
innovation of the web server Innovation
level of the house is complimentary to
Innovation level of the town then you
can build new kinds of towns in your
houses okay after that uh the third part
of part one more parallel societies
these are different these are more
digital and emerging um they're more
like Dows you know and crypto stuff and
you start to see how this space is is
converging so that's metac cartel
cordinate plumia Yim uh and the pronos
fund by Patrick Freeman that invests in
these new societies we'll also hear from
vitalic on zalu uh his popup not Network
state but what we're thinking of as a
network school maybe a competitor to
Harvard and and Stanford and what have
you CU it's actually already got a
strong research
Vibe then we're going to go to lunch and
after we come back from lunch um you're
gonna hear from Glenn Greenwald pauler
winner you know when that was worth
something maybe um and uh then also from
Ashley reinsberg and a law new house on
how uh the media The Establishment are
basically broken and how they're broken
in great detail and you kind of need
that because that's the criticism part
of constructive criticism and then the
second half is the constructive part
where you're actually building something
right so you need both criticism why is
it broken constructive how do we fix it
so um Nas of Nas daily nari scen and Dan
Romero will talk about building New
Media and new social media uh and uh to
to replace the
old um next we have parallel education
so we have as I mentioned synthesis and
Michael Gibson a teal Fellowship founder
tler con will talk to you about emerging
Ventures amjad will talk to you about
replit and you'll see how education is
being
transformed and um then we're going to
talk about parallel laws okay so uh
essentially what would a better system
of laws look like the laws are broken in
San Francisco they're broken for AI
they're broken for physical security and
for second citizenship uh and they're we
need to fix them for building entirely
new cities we're going to talk about new
legal systems and how we get
there uh penultimately we're going to
talk about parallel biom medicine which
is a subset of both parallel regulation
parallel science and parallel medicine
you're going to hear about new uh a new
biotech free zone a longevity uh
community and research Hub funed by my
friend Brian Armstrong on how they're
doing decentralized science and trying
to change the incentives for
science last you're going to hear about
parallel Finance that's another way of
thinking about crypto that's why crypto
people are interested in this because
parallel Finance is a crucial subset but
it's a subset of the entire parallel
establishment Anatolia will'll talk
about how salana has essentially built a
parallel banking system and salana
breakpoint by the way is tomorrow and
the day after and so on in this exact
venue so you can if you want to stay in
amam you can come to breakpoint um and
so that's the solution is a parallel
banking system then you're going to hear
about the problem which uh you know the
Winkle bosses will talk about how the
current systems failed on regulation
Cody Sanchez will talk about it's failed
on Wall Street and you'll also hear
about how it's failing on currency and
basically everything else so as the
beginning let's get started
so